[MUSIC PLAYING]
FEMI TAIWO: A caching
system basically
makes use of
technology that stores
part of your code, or
your content, in memory.
An example of where
this could be used
is for a newspaper website
or a news magazine website.
The home page may not change
for every couple of minutes,
yet it can have a
hundred, 500, a thousand,
thousands of users
coming to that home page
within that time.
It makes no sense,
or it's suboptimal,
to have to-- for every time a
user comes to the home page--
to have to go to your database
to pull what's the latest
news, where's the
picture, where's
the content, who is the author.
What you can do instead is
store that in your cache.
And once there's an
update of that content
you just need to
update the cache.
Every user who comes to the
site at that point in time gets
served content from that cache.
And there are several
tools that you
can use to enable
caching on your servers.
The first I'd recommend
for those of us
who use Apache is memcached.
Memcached is fantastic because
it runs extremely fast.
You see on line four I'm
[INAUDIBLE] an instance
of the memcached class.
And if you're using Google
App Engine like I usually do,
you don't need to
have line eight, which
is a part that connects
to the memcached server.
That already happens
instantly, automatically,
on Google App Engine.
Or if you're not using
Google App Engine,
you need to run that line there.
Let's assume this is a
fictitious days of week site--
days of the week website.
And what I'm doing
here on line ten
is checking if it's already
memcached the days of the week.
And if I don't get the
results as seen on line 11,
I then run my series of
logic, pooled information,
process the data
from the database,
to get the days of the week.
And after I do that
I start in memcached.
And then I can now
display the results
of that code in my browser.
Now how do I set up memcached?
It's simple.
If you're using
Google App Engine,
there's no need to install it.
It's already there.
If you're using a VPS, a private
server, a cloud, wherever,
right, then you should
go to memcached.org
to follow the instructions on
how to download and install
memcached.
The third, what I find is
the most important thing,
is testing, testing
with virtual users.
Testing to simulate what would
happen if a thousand users were
accessing your website
or app at the same time,
10,000 users accessing
your app at the same time.
What would be the
experience like if you
had 100,000 users accessing the
application at the same time?
What would happen?
And where are the bottlenecks
in your application?
When you have just 10
users, or a hundred users,
it may not be so obvious
where the constraints or where
the limits or the
bottlenecks are.
Since it's going to be a little
difficult to sort of have
a thousand people in one
room testing your app,
what you can do is to
simulate a thousand
users on your app
at the same time
by using tools specifically
created for testing web apps.
An example of that I
recommend is JMeter.
JMeter is an open
source application
that enables you to test
out your applications.
You can set it up to
test with a thousand
users, a hundred thousand
people if that's what you want.
There's really no limits
to what JMeter have
to do to test your web app.
And you can then
profile it to see
exactly how the app performs
on those different amounts
of traffic.
I have mentioned
three key things
that you can do to help
ensure that your app skills.
The first was key mechanism, the
second was caching mechanisms
and the third is
testing your system.
So check out the links
in your description
to access even
more content on how
you can help your app
to scale and sample code
that we wrote
during this session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]